every once in a while we do this where I
tell you some of the strange things that
happen behind the scenes here at the
David Pakman show and one of the things
that we sometimes do it's it's half
funny but I hesitate to just call it
funny because it's also kind of
concerning and sad is when people cancel
subscriptions for what seemed like odd
reasons and this is my opinion maybe
these are not odd reasons to cancel a
subscription and sadly as the show
audience has grown dramatically over the
last year the sort of unusual reasons
for canceling have also grown
dramatically and I want to give you a
couple of examples today last week as
you might recall I said Iowa can't keep
going first in the Democratic primary it
just can't happen and I laid out the
first primary shouldn't be a caucus the
caucus system maybe should be abandoned
altogether Iowa demographically is not
representative of the United States nor
the Democratic Party and yes the fact
that they so bungled things on Monday
night last Monday night also is more of
a reason for Iowa not to go first and I
gave this disclaimer which a lot of
people said David that's a dumb
disclaimer you don't need to do that
where I said hey guys I just want to be
clear I'm not attacking Iowans here this
is not a personal attack on individuals
who live in Iowa Iowans are great people
as far as I've met met you know a few
dozen of them in my life this is not
about people from Iowa it's a political
analysis and someone cancelled because
they said I was insulting people from
Iowa in that segment I got an email that
said quote David I'll probably not
listen to your show again I was a paying
subscriber I'm from Iowa I saw your
video about how undeserving Iowa is of
going first with the caucuses insulting
Iowa Democrats is disappointing I've
long heard about rural America feeling
insulted by the Democratic Party and
I've ignored it but the Democratic Party
in this state has had a clear openness
to progressive candidates more so than a
than a majority of the states in the
country I believe they meant and you and
your audience is willingness to belittle
the Democrats in this state despite our
boat voting for Bernie and Obama is
frustrating I'll just tune into the
Young Turks and Sam cedar from now on
they
takes were more measured this is trouble
guys that someone would watch that
segment and someone who is at least
apparently on our side believe that it
was about insulting Iowans as
individuals either didn't understand the
segment or something else is going on
and it is very very sad another recent
one is someone who doesn't like that
I don't think ford vehicles are that
great even though i don't even remember
the last time that this came up i
recently got an email that said david
stop bad-mouthing ford vehicles it
happened twice when i was a member on
your bonus shows
I will never subscribe if you badmouth
Ford again
I truly appreciate this viewer support
while I had it but if I don't even
remember what I said but if merely
saying I don't think Ford makes the best
cars which I don't I mean I that's
certainly my opinion and I don't
remember exactly what I said if that
warrants cancelling a subscription to a
political show that you otherwise are
online in line with we're in trouble
that's the reality I don't know how you
can watch any show if something this
minor is a catalyst for abandoning that
program just one more here David as soon
as you said that tulsi gabbard had no
chance on the Iowa live stream I had to
cancel my membership she is the only
candidate who will end forever wars and
I can't believe you are attacking her in
this way now this email is problematic
in general like in an election with ten
candidates some have no chance and
canceling because I point that out is is
not ideal but the person is saying they
canceled because on a February third I
said Tulsi has no chance
during the Iowa caucus result live
stream she obviously had no chance at
that point she got zero in the Iowa
caucus so this is really disturbing
stuff we deal with it you know
mathematically this is a small portion
of the audience but it does concern me
because of what it suggests about the
fickle nature of the movement and
fortunately it applies to a tiny tiny
sliver of the audience but I this is not
concern trolling this is not this is
nothing other than that really does
concern me because when we think about
we need everybody on board to defeat
Donald Trump everybody right really
because we need a so overall overwhelm
the meddling and the voter suppression
and all of this stuff that when someone
says I'm abandoning a show that I guess
I used to agree with because they said
something about Ford or I misunderstood
a story about Iowa's attacking Iowans
or I stated correctly that Tulsi had no
chance of winning in Iowa on the day
that she got zero votes if these are
reasons to abandon a show I am very
worried about what will happen in terms
of abandoning a movement that wants to
remove Donald Trump is the top priority
it's it's sad and it's scary to me quite
frankly